[Musique]
je vous propose maintenant de suivre
roger gicquel qui lui aussi est venu
découvrir le puy du fou quand ce village
de vendée et quelques autres sont
déserts les fins de semaine n'en
cherchez pas les habitants ils sont au
puy du fou
cinq ans déjà que cette population sait
que son destin culturel passe par un
grand spectacle d'été auquel près de
1400 personnes participent cinq ans
qu'ils savent que la culture populaire
peut être synonyme de réussite à tous
les niveaux même financière ce que les
grincheux et du mal à accepter cinq ans
de bénévolat farouche à l'échelle de 13
communes et ni l'usure ni la routine ne
sont venus près de 200000 spectateurs la
testerons cette année lui c'est philippe
de villiers créateur du spectacle et de
l'association du puy du fou
cet énarque était sous préfet lorsque le
château style renaissance en ruines a
été acheté par le département
il a voulu y faire vivre la mémoire
profonde de son pays natal le pays des
alouettes sur un texte très beau qu'il a
écrit lui-même dans un théâtre
d'expression locale qui serait un anti
son et lumière mais plutôt comme il le
dit lui même un cinéma vivant de plein
air sur une scène naturelle de 13
hectares personne ne sera payée pas même
les comédiens comme philippe noiret
denis manuel qui prêteront leur voix
la population s'est mobilisée autour de
cette idée une nouvelle race de vendéens
est née celle des buis foley c'est leur
spectacle leur patrimoine qu'ils
présentent
[Musique]
les puits follet ont réappris leur
histoire leurs traditions leurs costumes
ils en ont confectionné 3500 et les 600
acteurs jouent à la perfection les
gestes de leurs ancêtres agriculteurs et
ouvriers de la chaussure deviennent
délégation de tisserands et de potiers
accueillant françois 1er massot dans le
civil et le tout sur une musique de
georges delerue qui a renoncé à ses
droits d'auteur
[Musique]
les bras arrière le bras arrière
attention monde lra et 2
voilà c'est bon oui assez bon et pied
gauche oui c'est bien lever les bras
et toutes les têtes à bien ensemble
n'oubliez pas qu'avec les cagoules tout
à l'heure dans le noir sans se voit très
bien
[Musique]
c'est bon
trois écoles de danse 75 danseuses de 7
à 30 ans se sont greffés autour du
spectacle
tu es venu rejoindre le groupe
folklorique des joyeux vendéens
[Musique]
le
certains soirs
le puy du fou est comme un immense éclat
de rire dans les cinq villages coulisses
la préparation est déjà une fête le
cantonnier le chef d'entreprise sont à
égalité au jeu du palet comme ils le
seront tout à l'heure sur scène
[Musique]
bonjour répète le final au début de la
musique du final il est très lente que
très progressive
on ne bouge pas personne ne bouge et
vous êtes tous en situation les fagots
le canon etc puis premier refrain du
final on ne bouge toujours pas voir les
hommes qui doivent nous sépare captée
par lui et on bouge pas et après on fait
par 16 jusqu'à la fin jusqu'à lui dire
ses textes et ses cieux qui sont dans
mon milieu car on découvre comme ça on
sait qu'ils coupent et il n'y a pas de
problème
parmi les nombreux artisans de cette
réussite nous allons voir pierrot
herriot peintre en bâtiment acteurs
c'est lui aussi qui entre autres pains
les plaques de verre pour les
projections géantes dont son père
menuisier à la charge avec un projecteur
de 4000 watts
ça représente énormément de choses tout
d'abord je me suis je me suis inscrite
ou tout bêtement parce qu'un copain m'a
dit si tu viens pas j'y vais pas ans a
commencé comme ça ensuite bon on a pris
enfin on a monopolisé l'état lié à papa
sans lui demander son avis pour faire
des beaucoup d'accessoires que philippe
demandé parce que je sais pas pourquoi
d'ailleurs et on a tombé sur nous et
puis on a bien voulu les faire on a fait
des fusils on a fait des fléaux on a
fait des on a fait tout ça dans la bonne
humeur dans la gaieté le soir jusqu'à
dès minuit lundi matin au lendemain au
travail c'était pas forcément gegege
enfin bref le résultat était là il
fallait il fallait y arrive mais dix
mois alors ça c'est début mais cinq ans
après ce que c'est toujours le même
esprit maintenant il ya de l'argent au
puy du fou pour nous faire tout ce qu on
en est c'est toujours le même et ça même
si le bénévolat etc si si si le c6 en
argent pour nous tout ce qu'on fait
c'est son argent
on se débrouille nous-mêmes pour acheter
ce qu'il nous faut vous ne le regrettez
pas qu'en tant que sans argent
absolument pas moi je crois que le jour
où on nous donnera de l'argent pour
faire quelque chose je m'en irais je
prends mes affaires et je m'en vais il
faut tuer en nous la routine dit souvent
philippe de villiers aussi chaque année
la technologie moderne enrichit le
spectacle le laser vient d'apparaître
pour 6 effets spéciaux
celui-là redessine les contours du
château le laser fait partie du million
et demi d'investissements techniques
s'ajoutant à l'ordinateur à la cades
riffaud ni à la pyrotechnie au ponton
sous marins etc
électronicien et puis dès le début de
spectacle on va demander si frais
participer j'ai accepté et puis quand
laser et est arrivé on m'a demandé de
m'en occuper
on s'occupait j'ai découvert ici au puy
du fou la régie générale travail 3000
heures par an pour la mise au point des
effets sonores et lumineux qui sont un
produit dans les 250 mémoire de
l'ordinateur
on comprend bien ici l'expression
aventure humaine appliquée au pif
[Musique]
attention voici 93 guerres de vendée les
blancs contre les bleus
[Musique]
pour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur la brique éclaté et les parquets qui
s'ouvre dans les fumées tragique et les
flammes légère qui élèvent pour le
plaisir les fenêtres béantes
je sens monter en moi
la peine est portée damas comme un signe
le vitrail qui résiste aux fans
miséricorde visage de bonchamp qui me
revient mon chef
la main qui se donne une larme qui coule
le doigt du pardon à genoux les enfants
[Musique]